hey sherry it is the bowtie nate home  studio up and adam once again with my  favorite coffee cup uh giving a salute  to teachers and students and we can talk  more about that  now your overall freeway traffic map is  in really good shape here for your  thursday morning with one exception  we're going to take you up to the far  northwest where the nevada highway  patrol is on scene of a crash  this is going to be on the eastbound  northern 215 beltway at durango  we have a live camera up there looks  like that right lane is blocked although  with those flashing lights it's a little  bit hard to tell exactly what's going on  but nhp is on the scene  i think that's either a truck or a tow  truck that's also watching by  in the meantime the rest of the freeway  system is in excellent shape you may  have those delays in both directions on  the 15 between cheyenne and craig  we're watching all the roads for you all  morning long